What's the difference between doing a Dutch test and a saliva hormone test get from ZRT?
So a Dutch test is a dried urine
horrible test the saliva test is often it's using a different hormone. So
so if you dependably talk to so there's advocates to the Dutch test
that say that's the best way to measure
hormones there's advocates to the saliva test there's not very many advocates any more that the saliva test is is a very accurate way to measure hormones but
the real controversy is between a Dutch test and a blood test. So a blood test can be even a little more accurate than the Dutch test I think except the blood test doesn't typically measure
all the intermediates. The Dutch test I think is is accurate I don't think the saliva test is a very accurate test. However, let's say the person has done saliva horrible testing and then they're retesting. Well then
then maybe stick to that and continue to do the saliva testing. You have to you can't compare a urine test to a saliva test to a blood test. They're going to be a little bit different.
So whenever you've done it's best to stick to it. I prefer the Dutch test because of the intermediates and everything that a test or the cost of the test I think it's the best test. I don't advocate for the saliva test for
core buds but the blood test you could have argued that that could be a very good test too.
Do you have any experience with the test for a vial which takes blood, stool and saliva and supposed to tell you what foods to eat, recommend supplements and probiotics. No, I'm not familiar with that test itself.
It's so no I guess I can't answer that. I'm not familiar with that test.